I've got totally surreal video to show
you we're pretty familiar with political
photo ops at this point we know about
politicians showing up to hammer in one
nail on a house or shovel one shovel
full of dirt
onto something who knows for what but
Donald Trump has taken this to a new
level you'll remember that initially
Donald Trump went to Texas during
hurricane Harvey didn't meet with a
single victim of the storm spoke briefly
but instead of even mentioning the
victims he instead praised the crowd
that had turned up he was lambasted for
this so he went back down to Texas and
he did the strangest thing a pickup
truck shows up in Houston to receive
relief supplies right so this is
somebody who's been affected by the
hurricane and excuse me if I seem sort
of confused and even explaining this
because I just can't wrap my head around
what you're about to see here Trump is
handed a bucket of supplies for this guy
who's in a pickup truck and I think in
the car the man's partner significant
other is in the passenger seat Trump
only has to carry this bucket about ten
feet it still looks like the bucket is
empty Trump's holding it like the bucket
weighs nothing maybe it was actually an
empty bucket and this was just a staged
photo op but regardless Trump care this
is a guy with a pickup truck mind you
Trump walks over and tries to put and
does put the bucket through the guy's
open window like he puts the bucket on
the lap of the driver if the guy's got a
pickup truck right
you put the supplies in the bed of the
pickup truck Trump no he pushes the
bucket through the guy's open window and
then tells the guy to have a good time
if you're in a situation where you need
to go get hurricane relief supplies
after historic flooding have a good time
here's some video
hey can you handle this it's a lot of
yeah have a good time
thank you man yeah
thanks thank you man
have a good time and did you see how he
was moving that thing around like it's
completely empty
yeah just like floating in the wind like
there's nothing in this bucket well they
have a good time thing I think that's
just one of those parting words like
some people say take care have a good
day yeah they just didn't put too much
thought behind it no he doesn't he
didn't put too much thought behind it I
think you're right on there and then
someone comes over and gives Trump more
stuff to put in the back someone finally
actually directs him to put it in the
back of the pickup truck and they come
over with a box and then some water and
then Trump actually put these in the
back of the pickup truck take a look
all right putting the president to work
there is he loads this truck
the water
okay fellas
thank you sir you're all set but it's
good exercise all right good exercise
says the president really did she an
Athena Jones back good exercise and a
good time had by all at the hurricane
relief effort where people are showing
up for food food I'm surprised he was
willing to exercise though because
Donald Trump thinks that human energy is
like a battery and wants you to plead
runs out
recharge it listen I know this isn't
ending daca or pulling out of the Paris
climate Accords believe me folks I get
that but has anyone seen more bizarre
video that this was more cringe-worthy
than when Paul Ryan was washing what
were obviously already clean dishes and
a clearly already cleaned up soup
kitchen if Trump went to get gas for a
car I mean the guy who's so out of touch
do you think Trump would know you don't
put the gasoline into the engine like
under the hood that you don't need to
pop the hood to gas up do you think he
would even know that he just seems so
out of touch maybe you'd roll down the
window and put it through the window
yeah that's me buddy seems to put
anything car related goes right in the
window very strange video and do you
feel bad for Trump because he's so out
of touch this is worse than there was a
moment in in the Obama campaign against
Mitt Romney where Mitt Romney showed up
I don't know if it was I think it was a
supermarket not a Costco and he was
pushing a cart around and when he went
in he just loaded endless amounts of I
think it was seltzer water and yogurts
that's all he bought and then every
aspect of it seemed really really forced
and it was just super awkward that was
nothing compared to the awkwardness of
Trump putting a bucket of supplies in
through a guy's window well at first we
were criticizing Donald Trump because he
went to Corpus Christi and he didn't
meet with any of the victims he didn't
talk about any of the victims now he did
do you feel as if he's redeemed himself
Oh believe me this is full redemption
when it comes to independent media and
the ability of being able to play funny
videos he is completely redeemed himself
for sure very weird I encourage you to
watch the video if you're just listening
the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as $1
per month and every dollar helps to
support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been
really bad